[Music]
[Music]
don't worry I'm good this is just my
professional stunt double Evelyn oh
sorry of acara Evelyn you good yeah I'm
good I hit the ground for a living
hmm that's right really she's a
professional stunt devil she's appeared
in things like Luke Cage orange is the
new black and more so why is she in this
Apple watch series for review well
because the new Apple watch doesn't only
look sleeker it has new health and
fitness features including one that
detects Falls so here's the premise of
this review Evelyn and I were training
for a fight okay well more Evelyn's
training and we're putting the new
watches fall detection and fitness
features through the paces
turns out fake falling is really hard
seriously please don't try this at home
so get close to the ground bend those
knees close to the ground lift those
arms use your body there you go
yes turns out that the Apple watch
really does know when you're just
playing around nothing that's because
the improved gyroscope and accelerometer
in the series four monitor for risk
trajectory speed and more Apple even
showed this weird diagram during its
keynote of the three different types of
falls the watch can detect and so here
we are
I had Evelyn do a series of balls that
followed some of the examples that Apple
showed the first of all we tried was
during a fight with her training partner
and competitive boxer Michelle Herzl
Evelyn flung herself away and landed on
her back okay moment of truth fall
detected it looks like you've taken a
hard fall do we want to contact
emergency services I fell but I'm okay
what about a slip
[Music]
yep ball detected what about a trip
it's all detected what about a trip into
a tumble weird no fall detected if you
remain immobile for about a minute after
your fall it begins a 15-second
countdown and sounds an alarm when the
countdown ends it automatically contacts
emergency services and sends a message
to your emergency contact if you've
entered your age during setup and you're
65 and over fall detection is
automatically on everyone else has to
turn it on manually in the iPhone watch
out okay time out I realize these Falls
are fun to watch even funny but in real
life following is no laughing matter and
from these tests if you're prone to
falling the Apple watch would be a good
investment and that's not just for older
[Music]
chances are you aren't buying a series 4
which starts at $400 strictly for fall
detection it also features a new bigger
screen slimmer design and fitness
features so we tested those two what
Evelyn and I went for a run the watch
automatically detected the workout
although this only works for certain
workouts like running and walking so all
that time we spent punching bags and
forgot to turn on the workout on the
watch a waist in fact other than the new
EKG feature on the series 4 which isn't
yet available most of the other new
health and fitness features are
available on older models with the watch
OS 5 software update but you won't get
the 30% bigger screen which you'll
appreciate if you're a stump body or
just a homebody and the new speakers are
louder which makes that new walkie
talkie feature much easier to hear with
new antennas on the front and back the
cellular version which costs $100 more
seem to have stronger connectivity than
the older series 3 and the battery life
has been solid lasting a day and a half
if you've held out for an Apple watch or
you have the first or second generation
the series 4 is the one to get I guess
you could say I finally well fallen for
it
[Music]